bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got raj
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
thanks for having me absolutely let's
just jump right into your background
where'd you grow up and how did you get
into finance
sure i uh i was born in england came
here when i was fourth year as in canada
uh when i was four grew up in the
suburbs
and um finnish university
decided i was going to backpack for a
year across the world
and i took my canadian securities course
textbook which is kind of your first
foray into the investment world in
canada finally read it came back
couldn't find a job in the investment
industry so became a telemarketer for
investment advisors to find people to
come to financial planning seminars
uh fell in love with the the industry
got an opportunity to run some money
decided i wanted to get into the asset
management side
and started building companies i built
my first company
which was a hedge fund of funds company
that i later sold
and then i built uh i went to work for
that large company and then i
built another company and i sold it to
one of the largest asset managers in
canada
then i ended up working for one of the
largest etf providers in the world
wisdom tree running canada for them
and when i left in 2016 i decided i
wanted to build my own
and started putting uh evolved etfs
together
absolutely and so you're doing all of
this um it seems like you've constantly
had this obsession with innovative
technology or disruptive technology
where does that obsession come from when
we were starting to put
evolve together back in 2016 we really
wanted to be different
from the other etf issuers out there in
canada
the world doesn't need another or the
world doesn't need another dow 30 etf
canada doesn't need another tsx 30 etf
or tsx 60 etf where we really
focused in on is in disruptive
technology and there was a few reasons
for it number one
we saw a lot of growth potential in this
side of the market number two we wanted
to
bring products to canadian investors
that they could relate to
for an investment professional to sit
across from their client and talk about
the yield curve
or talk about dividend strategy is one
thing but being able to sit
across the table from them and talk to
them about
cyber breaches or cyber crime or talk
about e-gaming
talk about bitcoin it's relatable topics
that most investors are reading about
and are interested and can clearly see a
path
from an investment perspective as well
and that was really important to us
in terms of building these types of
products and we're huge believers
that the world right now is going
through its biggest transformation
in history especially especially from a
technological perspective
so we wanted to participate in that we
wanted investors to be able to
participate and so
as as you know we launched a lot of
firsts uh
in canada first cyber security etf first
e-gaming etf
first cloud computing etf um we were
close to launching the first bitcoin etf
but we were second by a day
but we've taken a lot of pride in being
very innovative
and being very fast to bring these
products to market
for sure because you've focused on some
of these kind of
core uh niche industries uh i want to go
over a couple of those but first let's
talk about the the main one the the kind
of granddaddy of them all if you will
which is bitcoin
and not so much because that's the uh
etf sector that's got the most flows and
the most volume
uh but really because i think that the
audience that's the one that they care
about the most and they're spending the
most time thinking about
so walk us through what is the
fascination with bitcoin how is the etf
structured
uh and then kind of how you've seen
adoption uh for that product so far
yeah bitcoin as you know has come a long
way in the last 10 years
um when when people started to first
look at it
we would often hear these these comical
stories that that were true but still
comical
like the first bitcoin transaction was
10 000 bitcoins used to buy
a pizza and if you put that into today's
term that pizza is worth over 500
million dollars
uh very expensive pizza i'm not sure who
the guy was that actually used the 10
000 bitcoin for
but i hope it was great um for the
hear heard stories about people losing
their security key
uh for their bitcoin and rummaging
through a garbage dump
trying to find their hard drive or their
usb stick to recover
uh the bitcoin still today 20 of the
bitcoin outstanding is sitting with
people that don't have security keys
to access it but if you fast forward to
the last few years
we've started to see a lot more uses for
bitcoin we started to see
wider adoption we've seen retail
investors continue to use it
we've seen institutional investors
starting to adopt it
we've seen companies starting to use it
as a store of value
for a component of their cash positions
in their portfolios we've seen it being
used for transactions
uh as well so we've seen a lot more
usage
of bitcoin out there in the market today
and that's what's created all of this
value so
you know you also have over the last
year a lot of people looking at bitcoin
as a bit of a hedge against all of this
quantitative easing
that's taking place in across the world
right now we're printing money
uh left right and center and we're
potentially entering into an
inflationary
period and so bitcoin can act as a bit
of a hedge
against that inflation so there's a lot
we use so back in 2017
we actually filed for the first bitcoin
etf in north america
but the regulators here in canada just
weren't ready for it
uh and i understand why there wasn't
enough infrastructure there wasn't
widespread enough
uh adoption as well we revisited it
a few months ago with our regulators
here in canada
they seemed a lot more open to it we now
have a futures market tied to bitcoin
that provides better liquidity uh and
stability and as i mentioned before you
have a lot more
uh adoption so we're finally able uh to
get the regulators comfortable to let us
launch it and
the great part about it is as you know
for a lot of people that want to buy
bitcoin
it's a bit of a daunting task to go and
set up that digital wallet
and access the security key so our etf
is actually buying
physical bitcoin if you invest 25
into our fund you are getting 25 worth
of bitcoin
it's not tied to futures it's actually
physical uh
so you can put it inside your brokerage
account and so in canada we have these
things called
rsps we have rifts we have our esps
we have tfsas all these registered
accounts that enable people to actually
invest in bitcoin the same way that they
would buy
any other equity etf so it becomes
a very efficient way for individuals to
access
uh physical bitcoin and so when you
think about the etf structure versus
let's say some of the trust structures
or the etps or etns
describe why the etf is so important and
how you do things around
let's say the premium or discount and
how that will differ versus some of the
other products people have seen
we will always be tracking the price of
bitcoin with an etf which you have is
you have market makers
and the market makers will always be
creating redeeming making markets
based on that reference rate of bitcoin
so with a fund like ours you would never
have a significant discount or a
significant premium
uh above the price one of the challenges
with a lot of the closed end funds
uh that exist out there prior to the
etfs in canada
getting launched many of them were
trading at anywhere from 10 to
30 premiums above the price or value
uh of bitcoin once the etfs came out in
canada
all of those premiums disappeared and
now many of them are trading at
significant discounts
to their actual value anywhere from five
to ten percent
so an etf provides you with
clear pricing mechanism great market
making
and most importantly intraday liquidity
you can be
you can invest in our fund and then an
hour later if you change your mind about
bitcoin
you can redeem out of it too you don't
necessarily have that option within
closed and funds
got it and so when you start to think
through how this will impact uh kind of
capital flows to bitcoin the asset and
the market cap
uh what's the thought process there just
tons of people show up and they all want
to uh
to buy the bitcoin etf and therefore the
market cap drastically expands what are
you seeing and how do you think about it
well when you think about bitcoin as you
know there's a limited
supply of 21 million coin right now
we've mined about 18 and a half 18.4
million
of it so we've still got a couple
million to go so you have a finite
supply which is one of the reasons why
people like it
as a store of value and also as a hedge
against
uh inflation so really what's been
driving
uh the growth of the price of bitcoin
has been
the growing adoption from the
institutions and from the corporates
when you see elon musk tweeting out that
he's bought up 1.5 billion
of bitcoin within uh tesla when you see
companies like microstrategy saying that
they're moving
all of their cash reserves to bitcoin
when you see
paypal doing the same and starting to
facilitate transactions
this just all furthers the confidence
that people have
in the cryptocurrency and it furthers
demand as well so
uh we're pretty excited uh over the next
couple of years to see how
bitcoin starts to become more and more
adopted a lot of people i think what
what they're saying is
that i don't know whether i believe in
bitcoin or i don't believe in bitcoin i
don't have the time to research it
but the fomo kicks in uh for some people
and that fomo says well why wouldn't i
put a couple of percent into this
asset class because if this continues to
compound
200 return per year which is what it's
done over the last 10 years
then that couple of percent could be
worth a lot if i'm wrong
and bitcoin's down 75 percent uh
in a year from now or two years from now
well it wasn't that big a portion of my
portfolio so it's not going to sting me
that much and that's what we're seeing a
lot of from investors from professional
advisors
and even from institutions as well for
sure and so when you think about uh kind
of the
the development in canada of these etf
approvals or i think there's a couple of
them now uh do you think that puts
pressure on u.s regulators to go ahead
and improve it in the united states
if that does get approved does that uh
essentially kind of take the wind out of
the sales in canada or
what's the thought process in terms of
u.s first canada on the utf
i've talked to a lot of people in the us
over the course of the last couple of
months
and i get mixed um opinions
on this some people think that the stc
will approve a bitcoin etf in the us in
the next few months
some other people think it's going to be
at least a couple of years i really
you know i'm not a fly in the wall at
the sec so i don't
i can't really comment as to how close
or how far they are
it's interesting that the incoming
chairman of the
sec has got a crypto background and he's
got deep knowledge gensler
has got deep knowledge of cryptocurrency
so that's why some people think that
uh a bitcoin etf is around the corner
it'll be interesting to see but you're
quite right
in that one of the challenges that we
have in canada
is it's very difficult to sell our funds
in fact it's prohibited
for us to sell our etfs or solicit our
etfs into the u.s
market it's also very difficult for us
investors
to get access to canadian listed uh etfs
whereas if you go northbound
meaning from where you are right now uh
it's quite different
it's very easy for canadian investors to
buy
u.s listed etfs which has been a big
challenge for us in the etf market in
canada
because oftentimes what happens is an
investor will say well geez there's
a cyber security etf listed in the u.s
that's got three billion dollars in
assets trading
you know 100 million dollars a day of
volume
and then you've got a canadian listed
cyber security etf that's only trading
two million dollars a day of volume i'm
gonna buy that us-listed one
so the great thing is for canadian
investors they've got a lot of choices
the challenge that it creates for
canadian issuers
like ourselves is we are actually
competing
with us etfs but we can't participate
in the in the northbound to southbound
flow
for sure and so when you start to think
about uh kind of where we'll be in five
years
is there uh multiple ets they have uh
you know billions if not hundreds of
billions trillions of dollars in market
cap
and it kind of follows like a gold type
situation where maybe there's one or two
that are the winners and in a major way
and there's a couple of others that are
uh smaller scale that maybe have some
bells and whistles to it um
just size how many how do you think
about that
yeah i think that you're gonna see i
think there's gonna be a ton of growth
in bitcoin it's gonna look
the growth of the etfs is gonna be
highly correlated to the growth of the
price of bitcoin
right ultimately if bitcoin goes down to
10 000
uh per coin in a year from now you're
probably not going to see a lot of asset
flow into the etf
but if bitcoins at 200 000 in a year two
years from now
you probably have a lot of flow so it's
definitely going to be highly correlated
to the performance of it but i think
what a lot of investors are seeing now
is and to my point earlier is it's way
easier to participate in bitcoin through
your brokerage account
via an etf than it is to go and open up
that digital wallet and go through that
daunting process
of having to set it up and buy the
bitcoin uh in there and keep the
security key and remember the password
so you don't need to do any of that um
with an etf
i definitely think you're going to see
more crypto etfs coming to the market
there's already been a few including
ours that have filed a preliminary
prospectus around ether
uh to try and bring that to the canadian
market so you'll see more and more of
these
um i would say that it may stop at ether
because
once you start to take a look at some of
the other cryptocurrencies
um and i would say stop for now once you
start to take a look at the other
cryptocurrencies
they are missing part of that adoption
they're also missing a futures market
tied to it and the futures market's
really important for a lot of the market
makers
to hedge out some of that risk that
they're wearing by having physical
bitcoin
as well so an ether uh futures market
just started a few weeks ago so it's
still very early days but those are
really the only cryptocurrencies that
have a
fluid futures market so there will be
more it will be tied to the price
uh or the performance of bitcoin what
we're seeing a lot of right now though
is some of the biggest institutions in
canada taking this really seriously
and considering uh replacing a portion
of their gold
allocation to the digital gold or
uh bitcoin and that has really
encouraged me because
when you know we're very confident that
you know we've we've put together the
best structure
uh in the bitcoin etf space and when and
when people start to look under the hood
at our structure like for example our
index
is the same pricing reference that's
used for
the futures market with cme so when
people look at our transparency
and they look at our regulation and they
look at our
reference rate we're very confident that
they will look at our fund as being kind
of the gold standard
for sure i want to talk about some of
the other um
areas that you guys play in with evolve
etfs uh the first being
cyber security uh bitcoin i think most
people are like yes that's super
um kind of innovative forward thinking
and disruptive technology
cyber security what was the original
impetus for uh for going into that space
oh it was it was just it was a
no-brainer i mean every time we think
about a product or a theme
what we think about is is there a
long-term investment thesis attached to
this
or could this be a fad now
we've had a really great track record of
being
on the long-term investment thesis and
not on the fad side
and when you think about cyber security
you realize the long-term investment
thesis for it
number one we all know cyber crime is
going to continue to increase
there's no doubt about it how many more
emails are you getting or
viewers getting from a bank that they
don't bank with
asking to click on this link to verify
their account details or
something that looks like microsoft but
it's not we're encountering more and
more
cybercrime or attempted cyber crime on a
daily basis in fact
um in the next few years cyber crime is
going to cost the global economy 10
trillion
dollars 10 trillion dollars that's more
than the gdp of germany
and japan combined okay so that's huge
so check the box that we're going to be
facing a lot more cyber crime
over the next 10 years the the other
thing that i love about cyber security
is that it has become a
non-discretionary spend
for every organization out there and let
me explain what i mean by that
if you're a us bank a canadian bank a
fortune 500 company if you have a
terrible
financial quarter it's not as though
you're going to stand up
in front of your shareholders or your
board and say
due to our poor financial results we've
decided to reduce our spending on cyber
security
right never going to happen they might
say we're going to reduce head count
we're going to close some
offices branches defer initiatives but
cyber security is one of those areas
that companies cannot afford
to reduce their spending on so great
from a recession resilience perspective
not necessarily depending on the economy
the last point on cyber security
that most people are not aware of is it
is one of the
very few industries today that has
negative
unemployment and what i mean by that
more specifically
there are three and a half million job
vacancies in the cyber security industry
today
so if any of you have a kid trying to
figure out a future path for themselves
you may want to nudge them towards a
career in cyber security because there's
virtual
guaranteed employment but the reason why
that's important to
up to investing in cyber security is
because of that massive shortage of
human capital
75 of all the cyber security work
that is performed for all of our fortune
500 companies
for our government agencies for our
banks and so on
75 of it is outsourced because companies
can't staff up enough people
to take care and manage their entire
cyber security needs
so the case that we make for our fund
when we're talking to investors
is by the way our fund all these
companies in the fund
these are the ones that are getting all
the contracts uh the outsourcing
contracts to protect
all of the government agencies and
fortune 500 companies so the investment
case is great and the last point that i
would make
kind of going back to macro on cyber
security
one of the reasons why it's become so
important today is because we're so
connected
i mean look at your desk right now how
many devices do you have connected
online
three four i know that uh like many
people i was bored during the christmas
holidays and i walked around my house to
count how many devices i have online i
have 62 online because it's you've got
your smart plugs your thermostat
so it's great because we're we're more
productive we're more efficient we're
more happier because we're more
connected
but the downside of it is that we're
also creating more gateways
for cyber criminals to access our data
and
2020 was a blockbuster year for cyber
criminals
they made out with about 25 to 30
billion dollars
cyber criminals so guess what lucrative
year means you end up getting
more cyber criminals entry in the fray
so this is a great long-term
sector and it's effectively become like
the utilities section
of the technology industry makes uh
makes sense to me
cloud computing is a another section you
guys have gone pretty heavy and to
explain that one
yeah you know whenever i explain um
areas of the market i always think it's
it's helpful to
think of your life 10 years ago and what
what it was like
if you worked in an office you probably
there was this room
on your floor or in your building that
had these file servers
the bigger your office or company the
bigger the room the more
rows of file servers there were that's
where the data was being stored
um highly inefficient right because
companies would have to make these big
one-time investments
to store all of that data not knowing
whether they were going to need 20
of the server's capacity or 120 of the
server's capacity
if they only needed twenty percent well
then they way overpaid
for their infrastructure if they needed
a hundred and twenty percent
well remember when people used to come
to you and say sorry
uh anthony my server crashed you don't
hear people saying to you that their
server crashed anymore right well part
of the reason
is because much of our data has moved to
the cloud
major advantages to companies because
what it does for them
is it gives them full pricing
flexibility because you pay
for what you use not for what you don't
use so it's like your light switch
you come into your room you turn on your
light you start paying for the
electricity you leave the room you turn
it off you stop paying
it's exact same thing with cloud
computing the other massive advantage
and the reason why cloud computing has
become front and center
uh over the last year is because it
enables users
to access their data anywhere in the
world
it also enables them to access software
anywhere in the world
and i often say to people that uh thank
god
if there's one silver lining of going
through this pandemic
is the fact that we're going through it
now not 10 years ago
because if we went through this 10 years
ago we wouldn't be able to use zoom
we wouldn't be able to use uh
cloud-based video conferencing
we would have a tough time streaming
movies off of netflix
we would have a tough time streaming
games as well
we would have been much more isolated
and it would have been much darker
period to go
through so thankfully we've gotten the
kind of technological advancements over
the last 10 years
that has made going through this
pandemic a little bit bearable but cloud
computing today
is going through this process where
any new company that has set up in the
last five years has gone straight to
cloud
but any of those older companies 30 40
50 years they have these legacy systems
and so it takes a while to migrate to
the cloud so that's saying
that you often hear that everything is
in the cloud
it's actually not true only about 40 of
our data
is in the cloud so we still have a long
way to go which is why i think that this
is a great area to be investing in
because it's actually still
uh early days for sure and so when you
start to think
through um kind of other areas in cloud
computing
what are some of the like more niche
aspects right the etf itself contracts
uh the the macro but are there micro uh
areas that you're interested in
yeah we saw so what we focus on is kind
of the three
uh pillars of of cloud computing uh
platform as a service infrastructure as
a service
and software as a service or sas most
people have heard the term sas
very very often on the infrastructure as
a service side
that's where you have amazon microsoft
azure and google those three companies
control
about 55 of the cloud computing market
so remember a few weeks ago the
announcement came out
that the announcement came out that um
it's funny i mentioned google and of
course my phone started speaking to me
the announcement came out
uh that said that uh that uh jeff bezos
was stepping down as ceo of amazon and
he was appointing andy jassy
well guess what andy jassy used to do he
was the head of aws which is
amazon's cloud computing business why
did he appoint andy jassy well i guess
you could read between the lines
which tells you that cloud computing is
a very
very important pillar of
amazon's future growth so it tells you
how how big it is
so that's on that side and then and then
where i really like
uh the industry is on all the sas side
the software as a service what we're
doing right now on zoom is sas
based salesforce was one of the pioneers
of sas or software as a service i mean
when was the last time you went to a
store to buy software to buy the latest
edition of microsoft
and i often say to people when was the
last time you plugged anything into your
computer
other than power i don't even know where
my disk drive is in my computer because
you just download all of your programs
and everything that you need
from the cloud so to me that's where
there's huge growth opportunities on the
sas side
for sure electric vehicles is another
area
that i always joke and say ask a young
person they say of course
all vehicles are going to be electric
ask an older person and they think it's
like you know the charlatans of uh
of uh tech have showed up in the
electric vehicle space so how do you
think of that one
so if you think back like 110 years ago
with the horse and buggy
and ford came out with the first car and
everybody said this is a joke
it's a fad never going to replace the
horses and buggies
it took about 20 years to eventually
phase out horse and buggies and i think
that's the period that we're going
through right now
with the electrification of the cars
it's not an overnight thing
but there you're seeing these big
bold statements being made by countries
and by and by the the auto manufacturers
um norway and netherlands both no more
combustible engine cars will be sold in
their countries from 2025 onwards
norway is already 54 electric
so within five to six years after
2025 so call it 2030 early 2030s
you won't even see a combustible engine
vehicle on the roads in those countries
but the big behemoth countries china
india with massive populations
are saying 2030 no more uh combustible
engine vehicles on the road
you're seeing it with the biden
administration making huge initiatives
in the ev market he just made an
announcement a few weeks ago that the
entire government fleet of cars
is going to move to electric he's
talking about all these charging
stations
that are going to be put up throughout
the us uh as well
then you start to see cut companies like
gm and volkswagen both saying now
2030 anthony which is only nine years
away from now
2030 they will not be making any more
combustible engine vehicles
they will be full electric so when you
think about
countries making the statement companies
the auto manufacturers making those
statements
you can clearly see a path to the
electrification
i got an electric car a couple of months
ago three months ago now
i love it but here's the big challenge
range anxiety
i don't know if you know what i mean by
that term but range anxiety
i get yeah every time i go to my cottage
can i can i make it to the cottage and
come back on one
on one charge i can't um and so i've got
two options okay
coming back from my cottage one option
is turn the heating or air conditioning
off completely
turn the radio off and i'm white knuckle
driving the entire
uh way so that i can squeeze as much
juice as possible or
i've got to go 20 minutes out of my way
to a supercharging station
to get a fl to get a charge enough to
get back
and sit there if i want to charge the
full uh car
sit there for about 45 minutes to charge
it as well
highly highly inefficient so
this is the issue that i think we've got
with the electrification
is the overall infrastructure which is
why i applaud you know the provide
administration for saying that
you know they're gonna they're gonna be
putting in 150 000 new charging stations
in the u.s i think that that's great i
mean we need to do
more of that in canada our trudeau
government has made some commitments but
nowhere near enough but that is the
impediment
for uh the adoption of that is one of
the impediments
of the adoption of electric vehicles the
other one in the past has been cost
and because electric vehicles are too
expensive but that costs the battery
it's come down about 75 percent in the
last five years so
you're going to see greater and greater
uh adoption of it
makes uh makes a lot of sense and uh to
me it's always one of these things where
these problems people will laugh at one
day in the future right they'll say what
do you guys mean you didn't know if you
were going to make it
but uh but it's a problem today uh last
one i want to talk about sorry i'm not
on
on that point you know what's
interesting is that there's this company
called neo
and what neo does it's a chinese-based
uh ev manufacturer
and what neo does is you actually you
actually drive into a service bay and
they swap the battery out
so you're in and out so you're not
sitting there waiting to charge your
vehicle
uh that i love that type of innovative
thinking
as it relates to the infrastructure
until we get to the point where
you know we can charge our vehicles
faster maybe even use
uh solar energy to charge the batteries
as well but
it's a really interesting time and i
would say to you that the car
is going through the biggest
transformation
in history right now not just on the
electrification
but in the next few years we'll have
self-driving cars on the road
we'll have autonomous taxis it'll be
strange at first to sit
in the back seat and nobody's at the
driver's seat um
but you'll get used to it and it'll be a
great way because think about it how
many people dread having to have those
conversations with the uber driver
absolutely and esports is the fifth area
that i want to talk about
what uh what's going on there and why
the interest in being the first etf to
uh
to give investors exposure yeah well you
go back again
think about think about your world 10
years ago you got interested in a game
you went to the store you bought the
disc or the cartridge
brought it back home plugged it into
your console
and away you went that's where the
revenue stream would stop
for the e-gaming company for the video
game publisher i should say
today's world is so different and so i
had
two aha moments in terms of wanting to
create
uh the first e-gaming etf from canada
the first aha moment was
taking a look at how developed and
intricate revenue lines these gaming
publishers
had set up so you know you download a
game off
for free online and then you have
something that's called a freemium model
where you pay for to unlock levels or
you pay for boosters
or in the case of fortnight you pay for
skins
and in north america the average
millennial today is spending 110
a month on e-gaming because of that
freemium model so that's a
huge revenue line for the gaming
publisher
but then they also because there's so
many eyeballs
playing the games and watching the games
now you have companies like coca-cola
t-mobile red bull that want their logos
in the game embedded because it gives
them brand value
and so they're paying the game publisher
oftentimes to have their logos
like i once in a while will play a game
called nhl 2k and
nhl 2k the boards used boards around the
ice rink
used to have these logos but it was of
fake companies they didn't even exist
today
they have the logos of real companies as
well and then you've got the tournaments
and sponsorships
advertising media rights so these
companies have come up with these
intricate business models
with multiple sources of revenue so that
was a big one
the next aha moment for me
was the viewership before the pandemic
you had stadiums all over the world
being filled with people watching other
people
compete in any game
i would have never thought i never
understood it it never made any sense to
me
in fact i did a podcast where i was
interviewing a professional e-gamer
and i made that comment to him and he's
like you know with all due respect raj
my generation doesn't understand why
your generation watches cooking shows
or home improvement shows and that put
it into perspective for me because it
made me realize geez well
what i sometimes think is strange and
what i'm doing is probably strange to
other people
let's not judge and let's just take a
look at the business side and say okay
well
if there's all these people going to
stadiums to watch other people compete
if there's millions of people watching
online other people compete
this is a real uh source of
entertainment uh for individuals
and so the viewership and the multiple
revenue lines
was what really caught my attention and
then of course the the adoption
i mean we have three billion gamers in
the world today that's
anybody that spends six hours or more uh
per week
and i think on gaming i think it's
really important
to not get too caught up in the
stereotype of
those teenage kids in their basement
with a bag of doritos
uh gaming because yes the teenagers
are a segment of the population but i
know a lot of 40-something-year-old
professionals
that go and hop online and compete in an
esport with their friends
i know people like my mom 75 year old
plus
that are playing games like candy crush
and games like word search games
so it has transcended multiple
demographics and has become so widely
spread
and then you can see how it gets fed
from there because
our smartphone technology is getting
better we're eventually going to have a
full rollout
of 5g which means your overall e-gaming
experience
is going to become that much better
because the key to the growth of
e-gaming
isn't in the consoles because there's
only 200 million consoles
in the world consoles meaning the ps5s
and xbox in the world there's only 200
million of those but there's four
billion smartphones so if you're a game
publisher
and you're building your game for the
smartphone market
with all of the improvements in the
hardware and technology and faster
transmission
you've got a real business i i feel like
the five sectors that you guys have
chosen that we talked about today
uh to young people no-brainers uh to uh
hopefully more and more investors every
day uh becoming no-brainers
uh i wanna close out before we get to
the rapid fire questions with uh a
return back to the bitcoin etf
um as you think through that what is
kind of your pitch to people as to why
uh they should take a look at that and
put in their portfolio
uh store of value and um
uncorrelated asset class you know for
example over the last couple of years
the relationship between uh bitcoin and
north american equities and north
american fixed income
has been zero to negative that
relationship
so it actually can really help
diversifying
an overall portfolio um those to me are
really the keys the diversification
aspect
the store of value and the greater
adoption which is just going to fuel the
price of bitcoin
which is why i think it should be in
people's brokerage accounts
uh you know i agree you don't have to uh
don't have to pitch it to me
uh i want to uh get into our rapid fire
questions and you get to ask me one
question to uh to finish this up
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
uh the most important book that i've
ever read
um probably
catcher in the rye why
i just it really resonated with me i
mean i it was
it was you know i i was undiagnosed
uh adhd growing up uh like a lot of
people
i mean it's easy to diagnose today but
you know i was not one of those kids
that could read
that could sit down and read a book that
was the only book in my childhood
that i sat down and read cover to cover
within a day and and and
and the reason i was able to do that is
because it was just so interesting
uh to me so i know most people would say
like uh
a business related book but that was a
book that when you asked me that
questions the first one that comes to my
mind that marked me the most
uh because i was pretty proud of myself
as well
uh for being able to i always heard
about heard about these people saying
oh i finished this book in like two
hours i was not that kid
uh so being able to finish a book in a
day was that was a
was an accomplishment that's a that's a
great reason
uh second question is about your sleep
schedule comes from our friends over at
eight
sleep uh i used to sleep like five or
six hours
and uh then i got an eight sleep
thermoregulated beds basically turn it
really hot really cold i sleep
literally on an ice cube and see like a
little baby now i'm a full-on convert to
the sleep religion
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that changed over the years
uh well when you get older you start to
go to sleep earlier
so when i sometimes when i talk to
people like you and uh
some people say i'll give you a call
around nine o'clock and i'm like p.m
and they say yeah and i'm like uh well
that's when i'm really getting getting
ready for bed
i am uh i'm an early sleeper and an
early riser
i mean i'm very good at getting seven
hours
i i'm usually asleep by 10
and awake by five in the morning
and then what i'll usually do these days
during this pandemic is i'll
work for about an hour and then i'll go
and hop on my peloton
uh for a bit and come back up and work
and get ready and work and
you know driving my these days because
my daughters are back into school i'll
drive them to school
as well because it gives them that gives
me that time i've tried so many
different things though like i actually
got one of those
weighted blankets um um
a couple of months ago i found it too
restricting for me i didn't enjoy it so
i stopped using it
i i love the experimentation and the
open-mindedness
i think that's uh that's always key uh
third question is more fun and you get
to ask me one is
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i am a believer and i'll tell you why um
chris hadfield very famous astronaut
uh is my neighbor and
um had a conversation with them one time
and i asked him that question
do you believe that there's life uh in
the solar system and he said no comment
i don't know if he believed that there
wasn't then he
probably would have said no there isn't
uh but the fact that there was uh
no comment uh tells me that and he would
probably know better than me
because he's been there a few times so
it tells me that
uh there there probably is but it's a
great debate because i debate this also
uh with my kids i mean i find that this
generation of kids today
are far more interested in space than
um than than probably the generation
before them
and maybe elon musk has something to do
with that spacex has something to do
with that probably
uh but my daughters are very fascinating
watching space shows so i was very
skeptical i'm i'm i'm a very linear
thinker black and white
uh but in that case um when i heard that
comment
i i i could see that there probably is
what about
you yeah i'm definitely a believer come
on it's just math
right just the the minute possibility
that there is not
intelligent life is just too small uh so
i'm a probability uh believer in that
case
uh you get asked me one question to
finish up what you got for me
what's the what's your favorite podcast
besides yours
oh that i listened to um i don't have a
favor i don't have a favorite
necessarily
i'll throw some out there that i find
myself listening to the most
so uh joe rogan tim ferriss uh patrick
o'shaughnessy is invest like the best
um i would say those three i probably
find myself listening
to more than most um but i also enjoy
uh kind of just when i see you know
people tweeting about a specific
uh episode and they're just like hey
this one's really good uh
going kind of listening to podcasts that
i haven't listened to before
um i've never listened not one time uh
he's a horrible host pete
uh peter mccormick from what bitcoin did
horrible guy like literally anyone who
listens to that is crazy
i've never listened to a single episode
but other than that uh every other
podcast episode
uh that uh that people do i really enjoy
compared to his
can i ask you a second question sure
clubhouse a year from now
people still using it or is dead
i think that there's two ways to answer
this drop
in audio experience game changer here
forever
clubhouse likely winner
could mess it up at some point some way
could be
copied uh like twitter spaces or
something like that as well
but i think that the the conviction i
have in terms of uh drop-in audio for
sure like that is here to stay i think
people
just want the experience is like wow
this is amazing uh the big question is
can clubhouse continue to kind of you
know
distance themselves from all the
competition that's coming my guess is
yeah they probably can but we'll uh
we're going to find out for sure
yeah interesting what uh what do you
think
i um i'm still getting my head around it
like i'm still getting my head around
nft's non-fungible tokens
um as well and i've been asked this
question about nfts a few times this
week alone
and never been asked about it prior to
this week so obviously the big
art sale and and um and the lebron
videos are making
headlines uh as it relates to clubhouse
i i think the concept of live
makes a ton of sense um i can tell you
two things number one i never pvr sports
because if i don't watch it live then
i'm not gonna watch it
uh um recorded because i just feel like
you've missed the entire experience
of watching something that's already
happened uh versus
uh live so i i'm a big fan of the the
live
uh medium and i i see it in our business
too i mean we do these webinars all the
time
and i find that you know we could have
500 people rsvp saying that they're
going to be coming on to our webinar
and 300 people participated in it in the
end
and then we'll send the replay around
and maybe two people will watch the
replay
because for them as well it's already
happened so i think that the concept of
live
uh is is a really good one which is why
i think clubhouse
works i have not used clubhouse yet so
i'm just
a student of the of of it i i'm planning
to use
it in the next couple of weeks part of
the reason why i don't use it is because
i use a google phone and uh you have to
have apple
uh to uh to use it so if clubhouse is
listening
uh try and make it friendly for the uh
for the android users
uh as well but anyways i think it's i
think it's a very interesting concept
and um i i think i think it could i
think it could really take off and i
agree with you
the drop-in concept is is great for sure
where can i send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about
evolve etfs
yeah we have uh we we have a great
website at evolveetfs.com
lots of stuff in there infographics
different media
a newsletter as well people want to sign
up for it we send out a newsletter on
sundays
with a lot of different articles about
disruptive technology
um so any information that you could
possibly need about our funds
uh it's there on our website all right
man listen
i really appreciated uh this
conversation i learned a ton i think
that your
focus on disruptive technology and
innovation is probably going to pay off
uh pretty well here for uh
for you and for folks who choose to get
exposure through your etfs so i
appreciate the time i'll do it again in
the future
thanks anthony i love the experience